all right well good morning and welcome
my name is peter bartlett welcome to the
simons institute uh and the
workshop and summer school on deep
learning theory i'm very happy to have
you all here
we run our typical thing is
semester-long programs we run two of
those uh each semester
um but we also run these shorter events
uh smaller events i guess um in the
summer
uh so this workshop and summer school is
part of the deep learning theory summer
cluster a big thank you to the nsf and
the simons foundation for for funding
the collaboration
um behind this
um also a big thank you to the
organizers for the workshop and summer
school marty street row spencer frey
suriya gunasika
preetim nakhiran and yang takso thanks
to those folks for putting together a
great program
[Applause]
looking forward to an exciting week
before
ngati says a few words about the
workshop
let me say a little bit about various
logistics things so for masks the
university strongly recommends wearing
masks indoors
for food and drinks you should have
discovered the snacks out the side there
and and the coffee we'll have those
during breaks
um please don't bring them into the
auditorium
water is fine
for lunch you're on your own
if you want to leave bags and things in
the building there are lockers on the
far side that work with a pin code
um
uh omid fire our videographer in the
booth there is going to be
connecting uh speakers computers and and
microphones and so on um
and
also a big thank you to elizabeth huan
who did all the local arrangements for
this this workshop
all right well looks like it's going to
be a great week looking forward to the
lineup marty
welcome and uh thanks everybody for
coming uh happy to have you here for the
week uh as peter said this uh workshop
in summer school is part of an ongoing
uh collaboration um
that involves both several weeks here in
the simons and in
other ongoing activities uh including uh
um hosting a
bunch of really excellent postdocs and
in fact
this uh workshop was organized by uh by
many of these postdocs i'm here
presenting but really all the work uh
like you know 99.9 of the work uh was
done uh by our excellent postdoc spencer
who's going to be speaking soon young
who i haven't seen
everybody sorry i can't see people with
ms uh and sorry i will be joining uh
later i hope
so uh we have a combination of tutorials
which will be a bit longer and most of
them stretch over multiple uh
meanings uh and
um
and uh
research talks the tutorial we we
intentionally try to have a mix of
mostly theory i mean this is
about theory but to stay kind of uh
we think it's important to be you know
guided uh and informed by uh uh by
actual problems we also have several uh
um
tutorials uh really about how do these
things look like when you know not when
we just prove theorems about them we
actually want to try to use them uh and
i hope you'll enjoy uh those as well um
we do hope it's gonna be a
active and uh engaging uh week with the
both good talks and
questions and discussions uh we do of
course want to uh remind everybody to uh
um
keep all these discussions both uh uh
civil and uh also uh uh progress things
uh so keep in mind of the time that
great we have uh with great timing we
have also actually a working uh clock
installed to help us keep track of time
uh and really to uh uh um
uh to ensure that things really do say
uh kind of uh productive uh and on track
uh
uh the uh chairs will um uh uh will take
a more active role and act as uh also as
moderators as uh is necessary to kind of
moderate the um
the discussions
so with that uh let's start and our
first uh tutorial is by uh spencer frey
and spencer fry who's a postdoc
here in berkeley with a collaboration
after finishing his phd in
ucla last year
thanks spencer thank you
okay
yes so today we'll be starting a
tutorial with something about
statistical learning theory and in the
second tutorial today we'll talk a bit
more about optimization and how does how
do neural networks and deep learning
kind of fit into these
okay uh
so we'll start by you know just kind of
getting the setup ready so we're going
to be talking about supervised learning
problems in this tutorial so we assume
that the outcomes y come from some sets
of possible outcomes calligraphic y
uh we have some
features x that come from some feature
space calligraphic x
we assume we have some data sets of
pairs
x's and y's
and our goal is to choose some function
f that goes from x to y that is able to
predict well on on some other pairs x
and y that we haven't seen before
and we can define good in you know many
ways uh you can we'll we'll be using a
kind of a loss function that takes uh
two different inputs from from this uh
label space y and output some real
number um so kind of two canonical
examples are for binary classification
you can have minus one and plus one
labels and you might be interested in
the zero one loss uh so the probability
of misclassification or uh basically
saying that if you're you're zero if
you're correct and one if you're
incorrect or we could be looking at this
uh regression problem and we might be
interested in something like the squared
loss
uh and so we'll be making some
assumptions about uh the problem uh
these probabilistic assumptions that
we're going to have some distribution p
over
uh x and y
uh which we don't actually know but we
do have we do have the ability to take
samples from it so we have some samples
x one y uh p of pairs x i y i from one
to n and then some test sample x y
and our goal is to be able to have small
population risk under for this test
example rate so the expected loss uh for
this predictor f uh if you have the
actual label y that comes from the
distribution
um right and so
i kind of uh
jumped the gun a bit before but uh if we
have a you know pattern classification
task where we have binary labels uh the
expected risk of the zero one loss is
this probability misclassification error
and you can derive analogs for the
squared loss or whatever loss function
you want
okay
so the key difficulty here right is that
we don't know what this distribution p
is we only have samples and so to try to
translate what's going on from samples
from a distribution to
some fresh example from the same
distribution we have to use statistics
um and so
the kind of main paradigm that we'll be
talking about is trying to look at what
happens if you take these samples and
minimize some risk on these samples and
hope and and try to characterize when we
can hope that's this uh test test error
um like a fresh test example that's
independent from these samples uh the
training sample is x i y i uh the hope
is that this is going to be small if
this empirical risk is small
and the trouble here is that if we take
some estimator that's some fine in terms
of the samples
this is a random function right because
we have random samples from a
distribution some function of those
random
random variables is going to itself be
random um right so this empirical risk
or you know the ri the population risk
of this estimator is going to itself be
a random variable
okay so
because it's a random variable and we
want to make it small we could either
hope for saying that it's expected value
is small or that
it's going to be small with high
probability
and so the kind of key question that we
want to ask is whether or not we can
construct some estimator
f hat n
that is able to compete with the best
possible risk achieved for this
distribution it's the best possible risk
could be you know defined in terms of
the
minimum possible value achieved by the
population risk over all measurable
functions from x to y
um or more generally you know this might
be a very strong
desire to get something like that we can
instead hope that we compete with the
best risk for some reference function
class right so we can say our hope is to
compete with the best linear classifier
or the best neural network and this is
something that we can kind of
uh this is a type of
assumption that we can make that we hope
corresponds well to with whatever
reality we think the actual problem
involves
and so this is what we're going to be
talking about is trying to understand
when we can hope that this
excess risk between the
estimator f hat n and the best possible
risk achieved over some function class
is small as a function of certain
properties of this function class
okay and so
if you just try to decompo you know the
first thing that you might try to try to
show that this excess risk is small is
to decompose it into two quantities one
that we can control
uh and one that's just in terms of uh
having a good estimator and one that's
just a property of the function class
itself with respect to whatever
distribution we're looking at
right so the approximation error is the
kind of is what is what we're losing by
just looking at this function class as
opposed to looking at
uh all measurable functions say and
that's what this f star is is the
minimum risk achieved over all
measurable functions
and the estimation error is the gap
between uh the
population risk under our estimator and
the best possible risk under uh this
function class f
right and there's there's a clear
trade-off between these two quantities
because if we have a larger function
class then we can approximate things
better
um
but we will see in the in the remaining
slides that uh you know this is
going to involve a larger estimation
error
and on the other hand we also know that
if we're going to have a larger sample
size we can control the estimation error
and this doesn't have any effect on the
approximation
because you know the number of samples
doesn't appear anywhere here
um
yes i think there's some text down there
i'm not sure if we could move it up a
little bit but we'll see
okay so uh we're going to you know in
the in this in the sequence we're going
to be focusing on trying to control this
estimation right because this is
something that we as statisticians can
actually do something about
and our goal is to be able to to
characterize under what
properties of f
this thing is going to be small
all right um so if we consider uh
uh we're gonna be focusing on on one
particular algorithm uh that constructs
an estimator uh which is empirical risk
minimization right which is something i
mentioned before where the we're going
to pick the
uh function within this function class
calligraphic f that minimizes the
empirical risk right this is something
that
uh
we possibly could do right we're going
to ignore whether or not we can actually
you know devise an algorithm that finds
the empirical risk minimizer for now uh
in the second tutorial we'll talk a bit
more about uh how we can actually
minimize this empirical risk for renewal
network problems but let's just ignore
this for now and assume that we're
actually looking at the empirical risk
minimizer and we want to be able to uh
to say uh when is this empirical risk
going to be small
if that implies that the population risk
for the superior
minimizer is also going to be small
all right so
uh and
i guess also just to note if there any
ever any questions please feel free to
interrupt me raise your hand
say something and happy to
answer um
okay so we
you know our goal then is to try to
characterize when the gap the excess
risk between as well this gap between
the risk achieved by the empirical risk
minimizer and the best function of the
function class is small
so we're going to decompose this into a
sum of three terms
okay so this first term here
is the gap between the population risk
of the empirical risk minimizer and the
empirical risk of the empirical risk
minimizer
the second term here is the gap between
the empirical risk of the erm and the
empirical risk of that best function in
the function class which is measured
over the population risk
and then this third term is the gap
between the empirical risk of this
best function and the function class and
the population risk of the best function
of the function class
okay so this term in the red right the
empirical risk minimizer is something
that minimizes the empirical risk and so
its empirical risk is going to be
smaller than the empirical risk of any
other function so this term is going to
be negative
this third term right so we have some
fixed function in the function class
that doesn't depend upon the samples at
all
and so the average of this quantity is
going to be the same of the empirical
quantity is going to be the population
risk because there's no
dependence going on here so we can just
take averages and and this will be zero
in expectation
so if we take expectations with this on
both sides of this what we're left with
is that this gap between population risk
of vrm
best possible uh population risk from
the function class is bounded just in
terms of this first quantity here
right and so our task then in order to
be able to control the estimation error
is just to be able to control the gap
here right the gap between the
population rates achieved by erm
and the empirical risk achieved by euron
so this term is troublesome
because
the the issue is that the erm is a
function of all the random variables x1
up to xn
right so because of that we don't know
that the you know the
the erm as a function the function
of each sample is going to be the same
in distribution right because we could
have the erm could be doing something
that depends very specifically on the
samples themselves in a particular way
so it could choose to do something just
for one sample because it's one sample
so we can't expect this to have the same
distribution as some test example
because it could have these odd
dependencies on things that we've seen
before
and so
we could try to do something trivial
or something perhaps naive which is to
bound this this gap by just the maximum
possible value that could be achieved by
this of this gap over the whole function
class
right
and if we can show that this quantity is
small uh as a function of n right l hat
depends on n uh
then we could have uh a control over
this quantity which would give us
control over the estimation error
right and this is kind of what we'll be
talking about in the remaining uh
remainder of this tutorial is trying to
quantify what what properties are
characterized what properties of this
function class f allow for this quantity
to be small right and
as we mentioned before
more complex function class or a bigger
function class will allow for you know a
better approximation error but
presumably there would be some trade-off
going on here where this quantity might
be larger if we have a huge function
class f right because that only gets
larger as we increase the size of f
okay
and so that's what we'll be talking
about in the remainder
um and just some notation for what we'll
be uh talking about in in what follows
uh we'll be looking at a function call
and you know the standard setup that
we've been looking at is some loss
applied to some function f which comes
from a function class so we're going to
be looking to this translator this
composition class of functions that are
f composed with l
and we'll look at z's that are just the
pairs of x's and y's
okay so just to you know reframe what we
were saying before in terms of l's and
x's and y's in terms of
g's and z's we're going to be looking at
a class of functions let's say have
bounded output so it's from zero to one
we have iid samples z1 to zn and then we
have some test example z it is also
identically distributed independent
and we want to be looking at this
uniform quantity which is the maximum
possible value achieved over the
function class of the gap between the
population risk under g and the
empirical risk under g
right and so we can write this as the
supremum of this operator p which just
takes expectations with respect to
samples from the distribution or for the
test sample pn is the
measure that's the empirical measure
over the training data
and we'll in the remainder we'll we'll
just be using this notation to refer to
this quantity u which is a norm over the
function class
right and
and what we'll say is that if this
quantity u this this norm if it tends to
zero this is called a uniform law of
large numbers and if we have such a
thing then we're in good shape to be
able to control this
this gap between population risk and
empirical risk for the erm
just you know rewriting everything that
we've already talked about
um you know we do this trivial uh upper
bound of saying that
this this gap is going to be at most the
largest gap over the whole function
class
reuse the definition of g to put it in
uh you know the l of f to put it into g
form and this is just this u uh norm
bound
great
sorry what's z
z is pairs of x and y
so now our task is then to care to
understand when this uniform law of
large numbers uh holds right
and and some properties of this function
class g should should determine that
okay and we'll call uh
this function class g a glewvenko
cantelli class
if uh for the for this distribution p
if this uniform law of large numbers
holds for this class
all right and just to remind people to
set up p is the distribution over z
z one to zeon or id
p n is the empirical distribution
and g is some set of measurable
functions that have uh you know r201 and
have finite expectation
and pn minus p we can think of as an
empirical process so it's a sarcastic
process
where the
we
have indexed this stochastic process by
the function class g
and this norm is given by the maximum
possible value of
this function of this process
um
in this setting we're not allowing that
but the erm could depend on the data
okay so
the first question we might ask is you
know are all fun are all uh functions uh
are all function classes equivalent
canteli
um
uh this is not the case um so for
instance we can consider this function
class uh that is given by indicators
indicator functions of finite sets
subsets of r
right so it's going to be equal to one
if uh
z is inside this set it's equal to zero
if z is not in that set
right and so for a continuous
distribution
uh
you know because the measure of a finite
set is zero
pg is going to be equal to zero for any
function from this function class
uh but the supremum
over this function class
is going to be equal to one for all n
so does anyone have
uh can anyone can
say why this is the case why why
why is it that for any fixed g this is
equal to zero but the supremum over the
empirical risk of the empirical measure
is equal to one
so we wanna show that
we need to construct some set
s such that
you know that this that we're going to
have that the empirical measure
is going to be equal to one
and we want a finite set
so we can guarantee that this is going
that g is going to be
this average of g is going to be equal
to one
any any ideas
all right so we could just take this set
uh let's see
just take this set uh s sorry
s
to be equal to z one up to zn
right and then it's the case that
indicator that z i
is an s is equal to one for all i
right cardinality of s is finite
right so one over n
sum from one to n
g of z i is equal to one
so the thing that goes wrong here is
that this function class is so large
that we can
capture anything that's going on with
each sample that is that we observe in a
very you know
not uniform way like we can just choose
to do something individually for each
example because this function class is
so large
right and and this is really the problem
for being able to have uniform
convergences
is that when the function class is too
large you come up you can come up with
these examples where you can do
very
sample specific things that will not be
able to generalize well
to test examples
and so that's really what we're going to
be talking about is trying to formalize
how it is that a function class can be
too large
and and what is it that makes this class
large and what quantities can we use to
characterize that
great
so next i'll talk about vc dimension uh
and so to to start uh we'll we'll need
to define uh this growth function
uh so i guess i'm going back to using
f now but let's let's consider a a class
of functions f that is going from x to a
binary output like 0 1 minus 1 1 also
the same
and consider a set of examples x 1 to x
n
and we'll use this notation f of x one
to n which is going to be the set of all
possible
uh
n n outputs that can be uh taken
when you're taking a function from the
function class and applying it to each
uh possible sample from this x1 to xn
so this is a subset of zero one to the n
right this is a vector of n values f is
going to this binary output
um and so it's going to be a subset of
vectors of n dimensional vectors that
take values 0 and 1.
and the growth function is going to be
the maximum possible size that this
set can be
when you take n examples from x
okay and and the key thing that that
that is useful about about this growth
function definition that i won't
uh
go into much more detail about is that
we can bound this uniform this expect
expectation of this uh u this norm
between
p minus p n empirical process
by something that's at most logarithmic
in this growth function
okay so if we can
characterize what properties of the
functioning class like
allow for us to have a small
growth function then this will be able
to say that we have a uniform law of
large numbers which allows for us to say
that population risk and empirical risk
will be close to each other
alright so what are some
let's explain over there
uh here
this one yeah so this is just notation
to denote
instead of saying x one comma dot dot
comma x n it's just nothing to say like
the steps uh of all possible outputs
this has something to do with
x one to x and over there or are you
just like representing that
uh
yeah so it's saying so x this this
notation means that we're going to have
a sequence x1 up to xn
and that's we're looking at all possible
n-dimensional vectors
that take that where the i-coordinate is
f x-i
okay
so the saying
if we can show that this growth function
is is is small like or then we're in
good shape to be able to establish this
uniform law of large numbers
and some trivial upper bounds that we
could start with
right
this set is indexed over a function
class f
right so it has to have cardinality at
most f
we have the size of this function class
f
we also know that this function class is
a subset of 0 1 to the n
so
we also have the upper bound of two to
the n
um and you can think about what happens
if this is actually equal to two to the
n
right so if this is equal to two to the
n this means every possible
labeling of these n that
these n
x i's
right so if we take a vector of n and we
look at
you know we can either take 0 or 1 for
each one
2 to the n such
such vectors
if this growth function is actually
equal to 2 to the n that means that for
every possible labeling of those
n numbers there is some function in the
function class that can exactly label
those
so if you can think about this as having
some possible random labels for some uh
sample of uh n samples and there's
always some function the function class
that can achieve that can exactly label
those n labels
then the growth function will be 2 to
the n
right and the thing to note is if we
have this growth function as 2 to the n
log of 2 to the n is n and so we get
something that's completely useless
right this is not going to say that the
estimation error is going to decrease
when n tends to infinity but
you know this upper bound doesn't tell
us anything at all
and so
we can define this uh quantity the the
vc dimension the
chinavangus dimension in terms of this
growth function
right so
we'll use this uh definition that this
function class shatters a set of d
examples
if the cardinality of this set
that i was just mentioning them you know
the number of possible
labelings of of these d examples is
exactly equal to two to the d
right and the vc dimension is the
largest such g d that that is possible
right so that's that's what this
quantity is saying here is that the
maximum over all possible integers d
such that this growth function applied
to these d examples uh is going to be
two to the d
and the kind of fundamental theorem of
statistical learning theory is that when
you have samples that are bigger than
this vc dimension
that the
uh expectation of this uh
stochastic process the the norm of the
stochastic process
is going to be bounded by something that
it has
it's growing like root d over n right d
is the vc dimension so as long as you
can guarantee that
the number of samples is bigger than the
vc dimension
we can have this uniform of large
numbers and be able to say that the
estimation error is going to be going to
zero
[Music]
uh
i
i'm not sure what the tightest one is i
think they're exact contents but they're
all equal to consonants so
you can take log2
all right
so
okay so now we've reduced our problem to
uh
one more question so um
here you're using each x1 x2
independently
uh so there's nothing
here that has to do with independence
this is just the kind of a set of
examples so what i mean is
if
x2 is definite one f of x one then
your character dimension might be even
though
it might be less than d
is it true
so these are all just combinatorial
quantities right we're just saying if
you have d examples uh from this set of
inputs x
uh does there exist some function like
any function from this function class so
depends how you define the function
class i guess but like if you think
about linear classifiers or a neural
network
you could maybe consider more contrived
ones but i think these are all
combinatorial quantities that don't
involve anything about statistics or
independence
to achieve the second bond do you do not
need iid assumption of these samples
uh to achieve sorry
to get the pc
yes so this is
but this is the definition of the vc
dimension does not involve statistics
right so it's the theorem is the thing
that connects
this using independent samples that
actually involves these combinatorial
quantities
um
right so
so now in order to show uniform laws of
large numbers it suffices to
be able to characterize what is the vc
dimension of these function classes
and so next i'll describe what is the vc
dimension of
value networks
so we'll consider
this class of
minus one and one valued functions that
are computed by a value network with l
layers and p parameters so parameters
here is like the number of edges in in
the graph
um and k hidden units with relative
activations
then this theorem by bartlett harvey law
and mirabian
is able to give upper and lower bounds
for what the vc dimension of these value
networks are so so we have and which is
of order pl we're in ignoring log
factors uh that
uh depend on k
and l and and p
and the thing to note is that this is
able to
to give a guarantee for
uh
having
as long as you have a number of samples
that's bigger than uh number of
parameters times the depth then we can
guarantee that this empirical risk is
going to be close to the population
right just by substituting in that vc
dimension
bound that we had before right we're
going to have a root and
root pl over m ignoring log factors
right and so something that's a little
unsatisfying about this is that the
number of parameters in modern neural
networks is is very large right so if p
is a billion and we only have 50 000
samples then this is not a very useful
upper bound
um
and so the hope is that we can do
something better than this
using some different tools
so that that motivates uh this other
complexity that we'll be talking about
which is uh rather macro complexity
um
so to define rhino marker complexity we
we take these epsilon eyes which are
going to be uniform uh rather macro
random variables so radomackers are
uniform plus minus one
you can kind of think of these as as
random labels in a sense um so say if we
have some examples uh
z1 of the zn
we can
think about measuring the kind of fit of
a predictor g
with these random labels by looking at
the average
of these epsilon i's times the g of z
i's okay so you can think of if g is
going to be outputting something that's
exactly equal to epsilon i every time
you get epsilon i squared and this
quantity is going to be equal to one
right uh and this is kind of it's kind
of like a correlation between the
epsilons and the g is evaluated on the
zi's
and so
if it's able if this predictor is able
to fit random labels as well and this
will be close to one and if not then it
might be something that decreases uh
with that
okay and so we can use this to define
the empirical rather macro complexity of
the function class
which is just the expectation over these
uh rata macro random variables of the
largest possible value that can be
achieved by a function class of this
quantity that's the average of the
epsilon i's and the g of zi's
right and so if uh for any possible
epsilon i write any possible labeling of
ones and minus ones
there is some g that exactly equals
epsilon i g of z i for is equal to
epsilon i for each i then this is equal
to one and we are not you know this is a
very uh
large upper bound on what and what can
be achieved and we might hope that if
you know there aren't g's that can do
that and this is a quantity that would
be smaller
right and so this is empirical because
it's defined in terms of zi up to zm
and the actual radar record complexity
is just going to be the expectation over
these zis that are taken for iid from
from the distribution
any questions
all right
so why why is this useful um well first
we can bound this
expectation of this norm so this u
quantity which governs the uniform law
of large numbers uh by something that's
the most constant factor times a random
macro complexity right and and in fact
uh if we're looking at just uh
variables which are bounded between zero
and one uh we have a very uh very tight
characterization showing that this
quantity is uh is actually
uh very tightly bounded to what's going
on uh with the random accurate
complexity so basically the
radiomechanical complexity will tend to
zero if and only if this expectation of
this
norm the uniform
law of large numbers norm
goes to zero
right so this is this is quite nice at
least now we have this other quantity
that can can be able to give us this
uniform law of large numbers uh and so
the question is whether or not
uh this gives us something different
than vc dimension like what else can we
do with this new characterization of the
uniform of large numbers
okay so the main reason why this is a
uh that i think is a much more useful
quantity to to actually use and
for for understanding statistical
learning problems is because there is a
calculus to random macro complexity
um so for instance if you have a
set of functions that's uh you know a
function class that's larger than your
other function class and the random
macro complexity increases
if you take a scalar quantity that
multiplies every single
function in the function class
that scalar comes out
if you just add some possibly
some some other function that is bounded
then you only increase your radiometric
complexity by uh you know by most uh one
over root
so this doesn't actually affect
much of what's going on right it's well
behaved under convex hole
and and one of the most useful uh facts
is this contraction principle which is
that if you take compositions of
different function classes
uh where one
with a single function right so we have
some function l
that is uh bounded in lipschitz
then the function class that is defined
in terms of that composition right so
this kind of g that we were talking
about that it was defined in terms of l
composed f
also only increases the radical
complexity by mostly constant factor
plus something that vanishes as the
number of samples goes to infinity
and so as we were talking about before
uh you know we often want to look at
loss losses composed with functions when
we're trying to understand learning
problems and so this is an extremely
useful fact uh for trying to
characterize the random macro complexity
of
function classes and to get a handle on
you know the sample complexity of a
given problem
uh c is universal yes
and so we can now uh kind of
uh think about what is the rather macro
complexity for relu networks right so in
the same way before we were talking
about the vc dimension for value
networks maybe having a
a bound that only the from rademacher
complexity could give us something that
wasn't uh easily available in the vc
dimension argument
so we'll look at uh let's say a
depth l value network where you know uh
sigma is the value activation
uh and let's assume that we have uh you
know for benious norm bounded in each
layer by b
okay so there there are stronger results
than what i'm showing you here but
this is a very clean and simple result
to show
so if we have any training set of data
where the we have features x and then
binary plus minus one labels
and the data are our unit norm
the random macro complexity of this
function class is something that grows
with 2b to the l over root n
right so this
this exponential l dependence is maybe
sub-optimal and there's a lot of work
that tries to improve on this bound but
something that's very noticeable even
with this result here is that the width
of the network or the total number of
parameters in the network does not play
an explicit role right here the only
thing it appears is the depth
and the the bound on the norms of the
weights
right so unlike in the vc dimension
argument where we needed to have that
the number of samples was growing with
the number of parameters
this doesn't actually require that and
then that's quite nice because
uh you know if we're able to say that
the norm
uh of the weights found by uh you know
gradient descent in a neural network is
small then
it is actually amenable to being able to
say something using classical tools with
statistical learning theory
sorry
so how do we calculate this bomb for
agora
so next slide we'll we'll go into a
proof sketch for how we might actually
do that
i mean
if we give a neurological degree just a
trend and get to the normal rate
so you can calculate so if you train a
neural network you can calculate the
norms of each layer
right um i mean
if it's not in this exact form you know
this is not going to
give you anything there are variants of
random macro complexity bounds for
different neural network architectures
i mean the problem is
and i'll talk about this later is that
you know so this this does
give you some control over uh the
the gap between the empirical risk and
the population risk of neural networks
in some regimes right where basically
where b is like smaller than a half
right then
we have something right this is
something that actually might be
meaningful
but if b is larger than n right then
this is not going to give us something
meaningful and
you know that you can empirically look
at whatever the norms are and you know
this may or may not be a useful bound
depending upon what the norms are um but
it just kind of depends upon
how you're training you know are you
early stopping or using l2
regularization
uh these types of things could
uh you know allow for this bound that we
have on the weight norms to be smaller
which could
allow for
more applicable uh
theory
but that might not be the optimal way to
train the neural network right it could
be the case that
the best population risk achieved could
be when when the weights are really
large
i mean if we're trying to network
the beef here it may it depends on the
training set right yes
so
that means your
the function class times uh
yeah so so there are data dependent
versions of of this radar
microcomplexity bound that can can get
around this or you can allow for that
type of dependence
what's presented here uh it doesn't
allow for that
all right sorry if you answered this in
his question but
you're kind of calculating the empirical
complexity when you're training your own
network why can't you just fix the
weight norms
uh
you're good or is it just an
optimization yes and it's an
optimization question right because the
question is whether or not you could
have small empirical risk uh if you and
how do you actually
constrain constraints you could do
something for weight normalization
yeah uh yeah i'm not sure what it
actually results in terms of gaps
between what is optimal or not but
thanks
if you had used vc dimension then the
complexity that you got was laying at an
l but here you are getting a complexity
that's exponential enough
uh
what's the trade off yes so so this is
not uh right this is a very simple bound
that can be the proof can mostly be
shown in one side um there's a lot of
work that goes into trying to make this
better
um
but
uh yeah
the exponential principle is
in b to del
yeah just because of scaling so
now that if you multiply
if you scale
the weights
with b then since every layer they got
multiplied the output gets scaled like
it keeps del
and so
just the scale of
scale is b to the l so since the right
the marker complexities and simple scale
don't necessarily skills b still
you can also
feels the network but that doesn't
necessarily scale the correlations
between epsilons
but this is homogeneous i i think that
that might be right but then there's all
the structure because those spectrally
normalized sounds and how they uh yeah
yeah you can embed a linear function in
this network so take a linear function
you just stack it you
uh predictors not thousand dimensions
then this
sort of
normal perspective is like
and
you can just take the linear predictor
with some norm and then
take the
break it up into product of a bunch of
diagonal addresses
each one of them would have norm
which is you know the health route
so yeah
it's true that you can get maybe
flex control in terms of other
parameters but if you're only looking
for being stored
we don't know if the two to the other is
type but then b to the l is right
yeah but the basic
[Music]
the product of the layer so whenever you
have kind of normal control and we're
only relying on normal control of each
layer you kind of expected some kind of
exponential
dependence
the first thing that works this
is
more careful
so what happens at b equals one half
like what if is there like a phase
transition of some of some kind of
liquid b is less than one half it's like
where you now want a bunch of layers
yeah i'm well i guess also because of
the scaling is if b is less than one
half right the
the output is going to be very small the
output is going to be accidentally
slowing down
right so you'll be able to guarantee
that the population risk is going to be
both the appearance of risk using far
fewer samples but
that's because the output is going to be
very close to zero every time
let's see okay because
[Music]
is this
plus minus one output though i thought
that you said the network
was a classification
yes but the
the so this app right this is so the
norms we can pull out
the network itself is going to be
something that's
one over uh two to the l let's say
okay so so yes you're gonna have one
times one over two to the other minus
one times one which is one
i think animal was asking about the v c
bound two uh
that one had a p right so that p can be
exponential in you know is that the idea
sorry that p can be exponential and that
was like a bound for v c so p there is
going to be a sum
it's not going to necessarily be
exponential
minus one yeah
so that's not necessarily going to put
the exponential amount
uh is it possible to restrict the long
the lower bound of the law
the lower path um
i'm not sure so the complexity of a
function class where the norms are at
least something
now the function class is
normally
upper boundary like e
might also be
a lower body by something
so the norm is
yeah i think that's awesome
to move on a little bit because there's
a lot of the other stuff that i wanted
to get to
um
and maybe i'll i'll skip over uh this
proof
um
yeah i'll skip over this truth and just
kind of start to
to conclude um
right so so what what we talked about in
this in this first tutorial is trying to
be able to show that the excess risk of
the rm can be small uh if we have
certain properties of the function cost
right and so how did we do this we we
started by doing this decomposition that
showed that the estimation error can be
bounded by this quantity
we took this kind of
naive upper bound that we're looking at
the maximum possible value that could be
achieved or the function class and
showed that this can be uh characterized
in terms of the rather macro complexity
of this functional class
and we talked about how this amount of
complexity is much easier to to actually
bound because we have this radimacker
calculus that allows for
using familiar transformations of
functions that uh we would like to do
um
and we talked and we we were just
talking about how
if we have this l layer value network
where each layer's weights are bounded
by b then we can guarantee that the
accessories is small if the number of
samples is something that's growing uh
with with the b2bl
right and something we kind of glossed
over and that i'll be talking about in
in in the next uh tutorial in
uh today
is you know this question of how it is
you know we're talking about what is the
access to vrm and that's a worthwhile
statistical question to ask but the next
question is how can we actually
guarantee that we can do something close
to erm in neural networks right so this
is something
that's that's not obvious and that i'll
be talking a bit more about in the next
tutorial
um
and
just wanted to kind of foreshadow some
of the talks that will be happening uh
in the tutorial tomorrow and and also
the some of the workshop talks
um which is
trying to
kind of
think about
how strong uh like you know what's
actually going on when we're talking
about uniform convergence in in relation
to what we see observe in neural
networks
right so so we've been focusing on
trying to show that the
gap between the population risk of the
rm and the empirical risk of urm
vanishes as the number of samples goes
to infinity
and and we mentioned this kind of
intuition that the random active
complexity of a function class
grows as the ability to fit random
labels grows right because this quantity
gets larger if f x i can be equal to
epsilon i and so this intuition that's a
the greater the capacity of a function
class to fit random labels the more
complex it is and the worse our upper
bound is is is something to note right
because uh
if there we can just consider this
situation where we have a distribution p
and some hypothesis class
where the best possible risk that can be
achieved by any function in the
hypothesis class
is sigma squared which is a positive
quantity
right and and we can consider f hat n
that is an interpolate okay so and it
achieves uh let's say zero empirical
risk right
uh so there are because the population
risk is bounded from below by a positive
constant we know that this interpolator
must be fitting noisy points right if we
have a lot of samples and there are
definitely some noisy examples
another matter marker complexity of this
function class is one
because whatever function class we're
dealing and that can guarantee that it's
going to be an interpolator must be so
large that this is going to be equal to
one
and so this bound in particular gives
nothing but even more than that we can't
really hope to have some type of uniform
bound like this right we can't actually
hope that
this quantity is going to vanish as n
goes to infinity right the absolute best
thing that we can hope for is that the
risk achieved uh by erm is something
that vanishes and goes to sigma squared
or not doesn't vanish but goes to sigma
squared itself right so this whole
enterprise of uniform convergence seems
a bit uh poorly suited for this type of
situation
right and this is something that will be
discussed a lot in the next few days um
and i just wanted to show an experiment
that that really shows that such a thing
does happen with neural network string
by gradient descent
you can have a kind of gaussian mixture
model of data where you take some
fraction of the training data and flip
them randomly right so in this in this
plot we have like 15 of the data is has
random labels
and if you train a neural network by
gradient descent for this data and you
have like pretty
very few samples and very high
dimensional data then what you'll see is
that the training accuracy converges to
100
and the validation accuracy converges to
the optimal 85 right so this is a
distribution where the best you can get
is 85
because 15 of all the labels are random
right and this is something that not
only just is true in experiments so we
can actually prove that this this really
does happen uh and this seems to
conflict with a lot of these intuitions
that we developed uh in the uniform
convergence setting
um i think
that will conclude
what i've prepared for this tutorial
[Applause]
there's a few more questions i think uh
we could take
over the question
i'm curious like
do you think when you say that this
or do you feel like that
yeah i mean i think i'm confident in
them in the other setting
as far as
theory goes right like we know that it
is the case that if you have samples
that are more than you know two b to the
l you will have populations as opposed
to the empirical this might be we know
this but the question is like what are
the actual
b's that we observe in their own numbers
right
if they're so large just to make these
things useless then
yes they're true but they're not
actually applicable to how what we're
doing right so in that sense
if you're closer to this regime where
the norms are large or where you have
you know
basically all the complexity measures
that we know are much larger than the
number of samples
then it seems that there is something
else going on that requires further
investigation
how big is the true layer map that you
train uh this holds for i mean like
this holds for with one also so this
sold for linear cost pairs or 500 or 15
000 it's the same picture
yes okay so we call it uh i think also
this will be talked this this whole
topic will be talked about a lot
tomorrow uh but we call it uh well first
we call it overfitting because then
there is some noise level and retrieving
zero empirical risk right and we call it
benign because it's
behaving optimally okay so this is the
kind of surprising thing is that you can
look at a an estimator that's achieving
zero risk on a problem where we know
that there's some noise so it is
overfitting to the noise but it's if
it's still able to perform optimally or
at least perform well then it seems that
this overfitting is like somewhat benign
and not as harmful as we may have
thought from hospice
um could you comment briefly on some
other settings besides uniform
conversions that you think are
interesting like in youtube convergence
are there
other quantities that are kind of
interesting to study
so they're
i guess
i feel like
these are the main
uniform convergence type tools but there
are other classical tools and system
learning that can use to show that the
empirical is close to populations like
compressing compression-based sounds or
stability-based bounds are
also provide this guarantee that the
empiricals of the population but doesn't
really take this
yeah so uh i guess what i'm wondering is
uh
so first in the statistical learning
setup
you
correct me if i'm wrong but you're
trying to say
that
all
uh erm so all like empirical risk
minimizers
have this property that they are also
that the empirical risk is like close to
the population risk so you're not trying
to distinguish between empirical risks
and advisors but maybe i again correct
me if i'm wrong but i thought in
practice like a lot of the time you can
have like a lot of minima
and then some of these are bad and don't
generalize well and then some of these
do so how do you apply the statistical
learning framework
if at all
so
so these applied to any erm
but
this is also true that the type of vrm
you have could could affect other things
that's going on this is something that
we'll be talking about tomorrow and in
the next few days
okay uh thanks spencer and we'll uh
continue with the second half tutorial
in half hour